On vous en a sûrement déjà parler...
Vous les connaissez...
Ces vidéos qui font le buzz sur Internet.
En passant du chat qui joue du piano, au canular déjanté...
Qui se cache derrière ces sketchs, aux millions de vue ?
Nous avons rendez-vous avec Thierry...
Père de famille de 45 ans...
Qui vit en banlieue avec sa femme et ses 3 enfants.
Une famille ordinaire, qui...
Il y a deux ans, a subi, un véritable coup dur.
Thierry a perdu son emploi pour des raisons économiques.
Les enculés.
Ils ont fait des millions de bénéfice, ils nous ont tous virés.
J'ai mon petit fiston qui a vu que j'allais pas bien et du coup...
Pour me remonter le moral il m'a montré une vidéo canular sur Youtube et...
Je crois qu'il nous a sauvé la vie quoi le môme.
Putain ! ah petite touffe va...
Amusé mais surtout intrigué...
Thierry fait quelques recherches et apprend que les Youtubers vivent grâce à leur nombre de vue.
Quand j'ai su que 1 million de vues sur Youtube ça correspondait à 1000 balles...
J'ai tout de suite su que j'allais faire du blé quoi.
Je vais vous montrer ma première vidéo.
Là, j'ai remplacé la pâte à tartiner par de la confiture de figue.
Sur les... sur les tartines de ma fille...
C'est râté...
Lysa aime la confiture de figue et a donc mangé sa tartine normalement...
Mais il ne perd pas espoir.
Au début, j'ai fait 5 vues sur Youtube, c'était pas dingue.
Mais bon, je me suis pas démotivé pour autant...
Moi au début je voulais...je voulais faire du porno...
Devant son échec...
Thierry tente de passer au niveau supérieur.
Là, il est 10h30, ma fille Lysa est pas encore levée...
On va l'aider un peu.
Lysa ! Faut se réveiller !
Lysa, choquée et asphyxiée par les gazs...
Met plusieurs minutes à reprendre ses esprits.
Hé ! Faut se réveiller Lysa, là !
T'es complètement con !
150 000 !
Donc j'ai senti que j'étais sur le bon filon, là !
Et, bah je dois dire que j'ai enchaîné avec un petit bijou.
T'as changé de boucher, chéri ?
Bah non, non...
Il a un goût bizarre quand même.
Ah bon ?
Voir, il est périmé...
Ouais, ça pue la merde ton truc !
C'est normal !
C'est de la merde !
J'ai chié dans la capote !
Le résultat est immédiat.
Malaises, vomissements...
Plein de bonnes choses qui garantissent le buzz selon lui.
-Je te déteste !
Je te déteste !
-Oh ça va !
Et ce n'est pas fini...
Après avoir vu la vidéo d'un cafard envoyé dans l'espace...
Thierry décide d'envoyer sa fille, Zoé, de 6 mois.
C'est 1 million de vue ça !
-Je te déteste !
Aujourd'hui, Thierry compte bien filmé ce qui sera...
Son best-seller qu'il compte appeler...
La Maison Hantée.
Ça, ça te démarre à 38 tonnes ça.
Tiens, regarde... regarde...regarde la baignoire...
Du sang de porc, j'ai mis du sang de porc.
Oh putain ! Ça, ça va être gore ça.
Ça c'est un serpent qui vient de...de...d'Australie ça.
Fais gaffe, fais gaffe à tes pieds hein !
Piège à loup, putain !
Tu me fais peur à chaque fois !
Alors lui, c'est un vrai psychopathe.
Il travaille tout à la piochette comme ça
On s'est rencontré sur Doctissimo.
Là, on va faire bien mal, putain !
Étant donné la violence des images de cette vidéo...
Nous ne pouvons montrer que la façade extérieure de la maison.
*Grands cris*
Bon bah voilà, avec cette dernière vidéo...
On peut considérer qu'on a plus de problème d'argent, hein ?
Qu'on est, qu'on a vu le bout du tunnel.
Mais je peux vous dire que c'est que le début !
C'est que le début !
Ça, je peux vous le dire !
Là on va envoyer du lourd.
Je te quitte.
Fais gaffe, hein ?